bienvenue à paroles autochtone si ces
milices au moulin du puits cette semaine
je répondre à des questions de nolan qui
me demandent que penses tu de l'adoption
d'enfants autochtones par des familles
non autochtone non aujourd'hui on en
parle beaucoup dans les médias
il ya eu une vague le sic sic le sixties
scoop ou les jeunes dans les années 60
se sont fait placer ou même adoptés par
des familles sans le consentement ou
même sans la connaissance des familles
de ces enfants là donc présentement il
ya une grande question qui circulent
dont le gouvernement canadien va devoir
répondre mais l'on parle d'adoption
aujourd'hui dans le temps présent et je
pense que ce soit une famille autochtone
une famille non autochtone tant que
l'amour de l'enfant est là c'est ce qui
compte le plus
cependant c'est extrêmement important de
se rendre compte que si un jeune qui
visiblement autochtone vie une
déconnexion où vit un arrachement sa
culture ne pas y répondre justement
serait une erreur parce que c'est des
problèmes qui vont ressortir surtout à
l'adolescence ou même dans la vie adulte
par rapport à se sentir déconnecté de sa
culture de sa nation il ya beaucoup de
programmes présentement qui sont
instaurées dans les centres comme des
centres d'adoption au dessin de dpj pour
pouvoir aider les parents qui sont non
autochtone qui ont aucune référence
autochtone à pouvoir connecter avec la
culture de l'enfant qu'ils adoptent et à
pouvoir aider le jeune à se sentir
connectés et justement à éviter tous les
troubles identité qui peuvent ressortir
plus tard quand on sent qu'on a été
arraché à une famille dans l'écriture
des présentations sur l'adoption comme
l'adoption communautaire ou l'adoption
traditionnels une pratique qui est très
très utilisée pour justement alléger les
fardeaux familiale et permettent à
l'enfant de bénéficier de l'amour d'un
parent mais sans perdre le lien avec le
parent d'origine donc ça facilite
énormément l'intégration dans les
familles d'adoption et ça permet aussi
d'élargir la famille
d'origine donc tu renforce le lien de
communauté et renforce le lien
d'identité du jeune nolan ta question et
externes excellente que beaucoup de
témoignages justement existe de la part
de personnes qui ont vécu le sixties
groupe ou de jeunes qui sort du milieu
de l'adoption
n'hésitez pas à les lire n'hésitez pas à
partager cette vidéo
et surtout n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
des questions à espace autochtone je
souhaite une belle salle